for [ __ ] for chiselers i meant to say
for shizzles
for scissors for shizzles chiselers
do you get it guys it's like uh
it's kind of via satellite today it's
this is a via satellite right
this is we're um kinda
yeah we're yeah uh bianca you're getting
squiggly
whatever i won't worry about that i'm
i've never been clearer
will will you're getting squiggly to me
maybe now that we're recording
interesting will uh there is a note
that says the recording's looking so
much better than what you see live
okay we're going to take your word for
it um
so bianca
do you want to tell me about your week
honey go ahead
neil i feel like
well i think you should tell us about
yours like
where are you did you sneak off to you
know
when the dutch settled america they
settled a place called new amsterdam
and over the it's gone through a couple
name changes now it's called new york
and i'm here because i'm gonna do a show
like three mikes
in starting in august tickets are not on
sale yet
but once they go on sale i won't shut
the [ __ ] up about it
um so i'm here working on that
with a friend of mine and
um been here two days
they kind of screwed up my reservation
in the where i'm staying
we'll get it we won't get into that but
there's it's pending guys
let's just say i deflexed my muscles uh
where i said i will do everything
uh in legally in my power to make you
look bad
uh if they don't rectify a situation so
um
how how often do you use that this is a
this is a
would you say justifiable are you
picky uh no i this is maybe a once a
year this is justifiable caring
and everybody knows it the court will
see that and
so we're just gonna make sure we get a
good uh outcome in terms of compensation
for what
what happened to me with where i'm
staying and then we'll go from there
i think it's gonna work out bianca um
so so i and i flew i flew
yeah and
you know i love it how did you like that
and i i
afternoon and that's where i watched all
my doc watches we'll get into that later
um but but no complaints and now i walk
around new york it's very sweaty as i
said yesterday it's sweaty money season
uh i all of my my um
my money is sweaty i got a haircut
yesterday
not that much better than what i did by
myself the guy did ask if i cut
my own hair in the front which is i did
so i'm glad that he saw my caught my
signature move
which is cutting straight across new
york
cutting things straight across and but
it did cost
fifty dollars which i didn't like
because it was like a barber shop i was
like new york
it's felt a little steep is that normal
um so
and the guy was they'll give me a little
added i want it to cost
25 as like the base price
but i'm i'm uh i'm a car wash guy i want
everything i want it to be 25
and then anything else is additional so
so yeah i didn't think i won't be going
there again i won't carry
them but it's right off sixth avenue and
[Music]
yeah so that's that's the long and the
short of it what about you
doll well i've been traveling
oh my god go ahead uh
so my friend got married in mississippi
and i've never been to the south really
i've never oh i saw that
pictures from mississippi let me tell
you i guess the first question is
are you safe well there are are you a
slave
not a slave didn't do ayahuasca here's
the thing about mississippi
right uh there's no one there
i'm sorry to say mississippi i saw about
15 people
there's no one in mississippi i was in
jackson which is the capital
meaning it's just desolate couldn't find
it
i found the party i did but
let me tell you i had to look so they
were at food spots
people are gathered at food spots so i
went on my off the beaten path i got
a piggy or sandwich you would have loved
it
um i got i just went to all these little
barbecue spots blah blah blah but
let me tell you something not a lot of
people mississippi
not a lot of people mississippi so he
went to that's interesting i just
couldn't
find them there's everything's boarded
up uh i went to the civil rights museum
that was uh was anybody there
everyone was there's a lot of people
that are silver right
so thankfully that is going on um
which one was it is it the one with the
the brian stevenson one with the pillars
no it's a new one the pillars
no it's it's actually i think this might
be the one but there is no
okay no brian stevens is new oh yeah no
yeah there are pillows there are pillows
you're right sorry the thing like slants
a little bit okay
there are pillars it's phenomenal it is
like
a little it's just a smaller version of
the one we went to in dc like
southernness
in the post civil rights era yes
yes will and it's so good and was it
heartbreaking of course yeah it's just
you're upset
and uh angry so it only talks about
civil rights movement and slavery and
all that stuff
in mississippi specifically which is
where
a lot of [ __ ] went down surprisingly
good start
it's a good start they only talk about
the holocaust in poland
well there's three million right there
so
you know that's a good it's a heck of a
start they don't they're not teaching
critical race theory are they honey
ew is there anything on critical race
theory
it was really good and then they have
other they have a
distiller they have basically another
like a temporary uh exhibit which is
about prohibition but how just like
[ __ ]
biblical and and viciously anti-alcohol
the south was
and it was scary there you go now we're
talking it was scary the signs were
hilarious
lips that touch liquor will shall
not touch mine for the women
it was very it was very like that's
interesting
it's like it's thick it's that's a
separate museum or that was at the
that was that the other one they have a
um that was just like kind of like an
exhibit like a
temporary exhibit uh but the an addendum
like while we're talking now that we
have you
um i like the idea of people fighting
over
[Music]
two uh two
curators uh doing like a spiver spy
over like a slave paraphernalia what do
you mean
like people fighting for slave because
there's so many museums now like you
need
yeah like do you have any slave stuff
just going to yard sales going like you
guys any slave stuff no questions asked
i just say i need whips
we need a whip for this exhibit there's
a hole where a whip should go
this is where my brain goes beyond yeah
it's no it's good you should um i don't
think i like it should curate i think i
like it
i don't like it anymore then i don't
like it anymore than anybody else does
um
so then and then i went to new orleans
and that was actually that
like everyone's in new orleans no one's
in jackson mississippi i don't know
what's going on
jackson mississippi yeah it just sounds
like
dirt roads it's not dirt but it's weird
just straight up and then no but it's
like it's got the energy
the essence of dirt roads the funny
thing is so i'm like
i'm always going to find the good [ __ ]
because i asked just locals so all
anybody got an uber from the black
people
were like now you got to get the
barbecue down here white people
different parts different areas they
were not
were they what is it
what were they pushing they
the white people were pushing a chain
sugary what's the difference is smokier
no the white people were pushing it
yeah yeah and the vlog you were like
we love we love colonel colonialism
and what is a chain but uh commercial
colonials
what we do bianca um have you been to
the south that's what we do it's what
we've always done
do you like the south tell me about this
i gotta say when i tour
i always say take me i only
go where like i've haven't done a show
in florida
ever i mean i did shows in in the
florida keys
like dove david off 10 years ago but no
not yeah i did like no i did the
yeah lauderdale like the lauderdale
improv but i don't have any fans in
those places no i mean maybe i do now
but
but like my feeling is like no i'm not
for these people
no it's because the black people down
there will never trust me no matter how
cool i am
and the white people are like you're a
traitor
so like you're a traitor to the race
brother
um i could probably do a small little
little place yeah i think so
i don't know why in my head i think i
just was like when i got off the train
in jackson i'm like this shit's racist
there's nothing going on but it's just
the train maybe that's your first
your first issue you took the locomotive
you take a locomotive but
to train did you jump off what how do
you get
maybe no those air travels back when i
tell you
were you riding the rails honey the
train from new orleans to jackson
mississippi is the most luxurious thing
you'll ever experience
bigger bigger bigger um
seats than than our first class
experience than we had together
amtrak yeah i don't know what's up with
our amtrak that amtrak is cool
our amtrak is terrible uh yeah
i don't i think it's i think it's
falling apart but yeah
good yeah they have bigger either you
can have bigger seats when you don't
need and you don't need to seat anybody
no one's on the [ __ ] train so they're
gonna have 40
40 seats of car whereas a plane there's
like people love it so they got gotta
you know they gotta pack them a little
tighter i where there's not probably a
huge demand
for did you sleep on the train that was
always my favorite you literally you can
recline back great train's great let me
tell you something about the south
though
i don't understand it's the it's just so
unhealthy
i feel really bad saying that because i
i had a good time on vacation but
it was really hard to find
veggies like fresh vegetables yeah you
know what
you know what never took off in the
south um
was uh civil rights and diet and
exercise
never really had their time
in the sun they're they're a little slow
on the
on the i don't even think we're gonna
offend anybody because i don't think
anybody's mississippi
even has podcasting technology no there
was a
i don't even think they know about
podcasts there was a lady that was like
that's what i think i was telling you i
had a figure sound she's like well now
you really got to get
some pickled pig lips now the pig lips
are
where it's at it's like neil's face
yuck i just i was like lips
how do they find lip like what i've i've
seen
pigs they don't have lips that i know of
is it [ __ ] is it labia
lips is it labia no it's
no it's their lips the south
still got something to say
it's it's okay i don't know what their i
don't know how their lips but
i've seen pigs i've never seen lips on a
pig i've seen
i have the term lipstick on a pig yes
but i've never i don't believe it that's
unreal
came from this i don't believe them
um well and it's a and the wedding was
fun
yeah it was cute everything was great i
saw a flyer fly for the first time
so cool i never said you've never seen a
firefly
yeah no we don't have them out here
that's usually i guess
all right i guess l.a doesn't i wonder
why that is
[Music]
i think they need to be california
doesn't sweaty
they're so cute have you did you like
sweating you don't like sweating i like
sweating so i was did you sweat a lot
i don't sweat a lot yeah i do too i'm
having a blast bianca
i'm building a froth just on a walk
question although i have yet
to um i have yet to
uh to wear shorts and i will not do it
just do it i i'll wear a round ball i'm
not gonna
i'll wear shorts right uh uh maybe i'll
do it
i may break them out but i may not no
promises gang i brought some but i don't
i'm trying not to wear them
let's um let's talk about the earth
bianca come on start it
we'll we have a cue for this don't we oh
speaking of which do we have a song we
want to play play the song well
i don't even know why where that would
go
just it's like i i mean you're right
that's all i care about
that's why why my first special is
called women or black dudes
and then uh dalia called his white
male black comic which kind of ruined my
title yeah too late
et cetera et cetera now i look like i'm
like yeah well black guys it just looks
it looks thirsty um
gender races are all the things that's
all i care about thank you sir
for your whoever sent that
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
it's got a real bill brasky sketch
quality
bill brasky um all right so our first
this first one is uh gender come on now
and it's about there we go
it's about britney [ __ ] free britney
[ __ ] they first of all lee brittany
alone didn't get any airplay
this week which i felt like it should
have he was the num he was og
you know what are you gonna do yeah
gotten he's gotten nothing um
and but what are you gonna do um
so i will you know the last time we
spoke about brittany
i was sort of saying yes but
we don't know like if the documentary
was like
sort of interesting um
but uh i mean it was
yeah it was good for i guess it was good
for what it was how
it just made it look like she was like
the pillar of rationality
and that the family was or the dad was
evil
and the system was evil which
may have been true my experience job is
is there's always like more to it than
just like
the victim so but
you read her statement
she's she's seems like a pillar of
something she seems like a pillar of
of um she's pretty stable
i'll say i mean again in in uh
what she read was stable like
um like it was it was
it was just like i just some of it's
[ __ ] gross
some of it was like dark and weird
and just how does how do you get to that
point with
your family member you know
yeah and it was also the
uh
[Music]
i yeah the fact that she hasn't been
like
she said i want to own my money which is
a funny thing to say
it's it's like what a it's what a crazy
person would say
except in this case she's not crazy
right
like you know i own my money
you know i own all my own money sounds
like what a crazy person would say
as they're being escorted out by the
police like you know i'll have you know
i own my own money
um i want to be able to get married and
have a baby i was told i'm not able to
get married
i have an iud inside me so i won't get
pregnant but this so-called team won't
let me go to the doctor to take it out
that of course that is is
absolutely disgusting
[Music]
and there's no way
it's just like [ __ ] gross now what i
would say is
i wish we could elect a few people that
we could
i wish iuds went in like a dart
and like who you there are some people
that should not be pro crew are you
darting neil
yeah well that's what i'm saying i mean
you don't want to go on the record as
saying
i don't believe so-and-so should have
kids um
but yeah whatever we should be able to
elect uh
we should be able to dart one person
even a sister-in-law
uh you know like uh just uh
just maybe some somebody you work with
um i think there's there's uh there
there's different people
you've got to have people you would dart
oh yeah but
that you can't some of them are men
some of them are men oh
i just did the black dude's name of the
camera gender
eraser from
gender or race
[Music]
it's a real fun loving end of the night
dr
john that's got a new orleans spirit to
it let's be honest
that is that look at this cord
yeah you're good look at this backlight
little dip i'm getting i'm getting a dip
and done i'm getting a little
fill it's called fill guys if you're
watching neil looks
very dynamic his face has dimensions
in this light and they're not they're
they're pretty special haircut
easy and then i have a window here it's
pretty it's a pretty complete video it's
um
i guess it was i stopped once i stopped
relying on will to light me and
uh just lit myself it's better it's
better looking
okay that's all i let go lit go light
yourself
um so that's the
thing she she wants to own her own money
and
um like
yeah i just it's just weird that gross
uh i couldn't even have a conversation
with my mom or dad really about anything
there were six different nurses in my
home
and they wouldn't let me get in my car
to go anywhere for a month
um i've lied and told the whole world
i'm okay and i'm happy
it's a lie i thought just maybe if i
said that enough
maybe i just might become happy because
i've been in denial
i've been in shock i am traumatized
so white ladies when you say trauma
um you know
you were just a karen don't turn on them
now
i'm carrying the carrots who will carry
the carrots oh christina aguilera
has just come out in support um
of brittany well so the funny thing is
that's exciting
so her sister comes out and makes a
statement and everyone's like
so everyone's like where were you this
whole time
never making a statement on a public
platform never saying anything
and now uh everyone
so jamie lynn spears everyone's named
jamie for some reason
uh is it's called uh
it's called white poverty go ahead i
think it's called the sale
and then her
britney spears's boyfriend hot gauze
britney spears's boyfriend goes post
says jamie lynn spears everything she's
saying is full of [ __ ]
so i think everyone is
she's a cash cow so she's in on it she's
like everyone gets so much
money from her a month that it's like uh
when's the last time jimmy lynn spears
worked when's the last time these people
worked
they get so much money from her this is
like the opposite of this is like a
reverse kanye
in a way in a way where it's it's a it's
an and
it's an anyak it's a reverse
kanye in that you've got this rich
person
no one could commit kanye to any sort of
mental
plan kim like seemed to influence him
toward it
um but when you're that when you're the
when everyone works for you
no one can can compel you to do anything
right um and and
like that so or so then the opposite is
everyone works for you and they can
compel you because you did enough
publicly
crazy [ __ ] and and the i guess the
children probably didn't help although
connie's got kids too so i don't know
what
i mean but i guess if you're a lady well
yeah if there was a convict
conservatorship
on kanye he'd be in a dungeon somewhere
[Music]
um he'd be in a in a dark beautiful
fantasy as foreign
um you're a professional that's me i'm a
phil
is a professional a fan of my black dark
blue i can never remember the name of
that black dark
whoa my dark beautiful fan blo is it
black dark
no the word black in it not at all
oh i just see it everywhere bianca
um so
first of all i can't i mean if she
doesn't
like that every britney show from now on
she's got to come out
in in a straightjacket like they used to
do
like with ozzy osbourne and tupa i'm
sure tupac did that i mean he did the
cover vibe
in straight jacket uh come out and
straight jacket and then
fight spend the whole show she's got a
[ __ ] narrative now boy
yeah now um that isn't just about hits
make an
album on this [ __ ] everyone would listen
ah nah come on i wouldn't listen
i mean if it was if she was a poetic
person if i'd listen but she's not
she's she's never written a song in her
life so um
but if she had bubba bangers i would
listen
do you do you know that you know that
you know that
bianca you know that honey honey you
know that about me you know that i love
bangers
and you know a lot of narratives i'm not
gonna lie neil i like
new york neil is uh he's he's fresh he's
he's hip he's i there's a level i want
to get to that i haven't gotten to yet
i like here's what i like about my world
right now
i'm basically just walk i like walking
or i walk
seven miles yesterday yeah i really like
walking around
and um
because we're just like planning a show
loosely there's
almost no stress oh that's lovely other
than just like i'm gonna do the show but
but i've tried it a little bit there's
no stress on
planning a show that has ticketed sales
come on it doesn't have to get sales yet
that will happen
um it's britney [ __ ] um free yeah well
but whatever by the time we
by the time we get there it'll be worked
out it's already pretty worked i did it
once it like
basically works i just have to tinker
you're the least stressed
you're the least stressful guy in
showbiz right now i'm like you're like
not stressed at all
it's weird yeah i don't yeah i don't
you're more stressed
but i realized i remember it way more
stress but i remember
plus you guys are in my house shut up um
you know whales of you guys you're
putting your makeup on
uh no it's nice it's nice it's uh it's
very nice yeah so britney's thing is sad
and
it looks like she's gonna get out of it
but it's gonna take a while
now it's just process right
and when you realize it's
it's like the wa it's like that that
we're gonna i'm i wanted to
follow up on this we're gonna do a
follow-up in nine months you're like
lady i'm [ __ ] dying today
well also the whole thing you know when
you start learning weird things about
your country
like you can marry children if the
parent consents to it or just these
weird loopholes
this thing is weird as [ __ ] to me it's
like oh and i understand it's generally
for people with like dementia or
degenerative diseases where someone has
to literally
control your life because you're losing
control of it
but when you see it like that it's a
little scary
it's a little uh rapunzel
in the tower i don't know it's it's just
scary that legally you can completely
get it
you know it's also the thing that i'm
always against which is
child showbiz people
she was too young these people are not
human beings so
by the time they
even like get involved i don't know it's
just she was like a disney kid
right and i'm sure she wanted to do it
but
it takes a lot to not lose your [ __ ]
mind
or to just be like a machine like
timberlake
yeah you know um but a lot of these
people it feels like a
coin toss in terms of like can you hold
on
right um and not lose your mind
uh there was that thing that there was a
dock that we didn't dock watch it but
it was like kid 90s or something did you
watch that mid-90s hulu
it's about the girl who now is a girl
who played punky brewster
oh yes it is she has a weird name
like sale moon fry there we go um
what's weird about that and um so
so yeah but but uh did you watch it
a lot of them died yeah i did a lot of
them
died so it's not a good
a lot of the kid actors from the 90s
died
um oh my god like they just got it's
like corey hell
feldman and raheem and just all like
well you know fellman i think still
alive but you know uh
it's just a bad luck it's a it's it's a
bad life
well also it's a great life for a second
and then it gets bad
also i think remember uh like maybe last
year we talked about that article that
came out
on how they literally did a huge study
on measuring success and how
to be successful you have to fail early
ever since i read that article and i
know a lot of child actors and
it's winnings too early and not
understanding why you're winning
it just i think it messes with them so
then when you
hit puberty you can't book or you're
this like you're
assigned such a value at a young age
that like it it's just really hard to it
just doesn't age well
that mental state of winning it's a bad
it's not good for a kid to go through
that
to go through professional rejection
yeah it's not good for an adult but it's
especially not good for a kid like
it's [ __ ] not and make yourself a
product
it's just not by not realizing that like
oh it's because your eyes are
like this and your voice is like like
it's nothing they really
have a full grasp of just like you're
what you are your product is about to
expire
yeah because you grow out of it you're
about to
grow out of this and
so it's just a gross
so you open a store and base your worth
off of this
thing that you are at age 10 and then at
age 12
you become like poison
[Music]
everything in your store is cute at 10
and then you
yeah your whole story is the whole
inventory is poison
um so but that's the problem with you
can't make a store around a thing that's
growing into a new thing
you might be able to open a new store
but
the fact that that those stores are very
unrelated
right um jodie foster is like a
continuation of what she was as a kid
or timberlake or oh um there's a few
people that aren't
friends that's the same story your
friend's wife uh
euget collins wife colin jost
yeah scarlett johansson she's been
acting since she was a kid
oh yeah she was in ghost world yeah she
was yeah
there's some people that yeah she was a
she was but and and the weird thing was
she was always playing
a precocious kind of over it
right in ghost world she's like sort of
like over it like conic
and then she grew into like a beautiful
woman
and she cut that's one of the things she
can do yeah she hasn't really had to do
it but like
she was uh natalie portman's another one
you know like was an old soul which is
just creepy
creepy old man for i want to i want to
have sex with that 13 year old
um so you call her an old soul um and
people
think it's cool and it's gross um look
great people are different um okay
so that's brittany and then
um rudy it's rudy [ __ ] rudy giuliani
got
disbarred rudy [ __ ] he got it
yeah in the state of new york he got
dis barred and
for representing all those weird
[ __ ] i don't
just he was just not it was illegal what
he was doing so it was like
they just had to disbar him i mean again
the the way the right has set [ __ ] up
they'll make it seem like a conspiracy
that they're the victims of but
they just got disbarred like straight up
and no one will believe me but after 9
11
he was a hero yeah no it's uh he was
america's mayor
and um and
and then he became an absolute
pathetic whatever i don't even know what
you call him anymore he's like just an
opera this is like a guy who's just
addicted to
being in the being in the know yeah
being in the scene
and like trump was his only way back
yeah um
so he he like exploited it or or
he it was all he could do it's like he
was like some you ever see um
sunset boulevard yeah he was like the
butler
like the crazy butler to this aging star
i mean
trump's an agent star but at the same
time he's the biggest star in america
was thinking again about the fact that
donald trump beat every
person on television including
cop and hospital shows
[Music]
basically by himself on the apprentice
still incredible i love the apprentice
cannot be overstated
what a big what how what a good tv
character donald trump yeah he's perfect
um he did he had a rally this week
and he's still got the old hits oh what
um didn't watch it but
um is it like watching it is it like
when the temptations come to your
casino yeah he should wear the
temptation
suits that i don't like the sort of sexy
paisley yeah you hate this
bedazzled that i don't like um
he's just like rot like an eisley
brother
he should have steps he should do like
one
two step one two step uh he should have
donal don and um the other son
and the daughters do back up this could
this has
legs this could this be a good sketch
this could work
now now this is will will you play the
gender race song honey
this is race i'll take race for uh
800. derek chauvin
come on right can but this is a long ass
week wasn't it
yeah so much should happen like i was
like i can't like that feels like a
million years ago
yeah um so
22 years 0.5 and
because 22 and a half
um because of the way the internet is
everything is uh there's blowback
or there's whatever as a
brown woman
what how did you feel about the sentence
it feels
it feels low for killing someone just
i i yeah i am a i watch it well
pre-ayahuasca i've watched i am obsessed
with murder shows and
everything having truth murder i know
i know what i know literally like how to
kill people
unfortunately and how to not really get
detected
uh if you just watch enough of that [ __ ]
so
as a good to know
dude erase that i'm not there
um no gender erase
go uh yeah so there's just certain
things whatever
the point is that if you are obsessed
with that kind of
that part of the justice system is it's
pretty low
uh but for a cop it's
but it's not that well i'll say this
it's not that low right like
well 25
so it's just under the minimum
so it's under but that that that's also
like different degrees
and also once you really get into city
state and federal uh laws
minimums based on certain thing
it it ends up being um just a math
game and your feelings have nothing it
was a little below the minimum though
right
but wasn't it wasn't he expected or or
the judge could have given him 40 or so
he could have given him more
but i also think for a cop it's like
wild
it's like it's a life sentence for a cop
and it's a lifestyle
i mean he's gonna be there for a cop
[Music]
but what i'm saying is it's a life
sentence meaning usually they get
uh oh yeah they're on on administrative
leave like a month
and this is a little worse than
administrative leave
um this is literally
jail did you hear how uh when they were
debating
his sentence that his his attorney
offered
uh five years probation it was like
oh they should have taken it um
yeah um the uh
the yeah i i thought
you know like i said a lot of people
were like this isn't enough
and then it's also the people that are
probably in the same at the next day are
for criminal justice reform
and sentence reform and and so
i you know the thing with criminal
justice reform is you can't go except
for my
thing right that's everything that means
a lot to me
and when you look around the world 25
years
is wild like getting not
not in super corrupt parts of the world
but like let's say in europe or in some
places in
places yeah
no places we look to to mirror our
demands you get that for like for
chewing gum in singapore they getting
25 years is like you yeah western
countries yes
you 25 years is crazy you killed the
president and here it's like
it's going to be out of life yeah that's
just like a minimum yeah
so i don't know it really depends on how
you look at it as a brown woman ion
i i am skeptical i think this is a flash
of the pot
i don't think a bunch of cops are going
to start getting
harsher sentences
well will you play game in my pocket
[Music]
it's actually the um the term
sweetie i'm gonna i'm uh doing a uh
literary caring um which is it's uh
i knew that damn it i knew that slashing
the pot
well if you get that pot hot enough for
sure okay you will yeah
sorry there might be there might be a
if the pot's hot oh if you get the pot i
don't know if you have to move the flash
over the pot
from the pan to the pot um
the plot is hot the plot is hot
that's my favorite also everyone funny
enough money right everyone in the south
is still dressing like it's 2000 um
so athleans yeah
a lot of the country is 15 years behind
the rest of the country
so even like you know
i was listening to george pacquiao giant
shorts
yeah yeah bling um
[Music]
like little chingy little chingy style
oh yeah there that's the south is where
like they're kind of
inter their intermixing racial equality
conclusion yeah
oh uh uh the george packer who's a
really really great writer was on
franken's podcast
uh but he was saying that like it's the
there's like a bunch of different kinds
of american one of them is like smart
america
and real america
uh resents smart america for just
constantly talking down to them and
it's all that davos [ __ ] it's i've been
saying it for a long time where it's
like going to davos in the learn
and the uh that and tech forums
and just a bunch of panels and people
looking at
watching panels thoughtfully and ted
talks and just like
shut the [ __ ] up it yeah for people that
aren't in it
it's loathsome um it slows them in a way
that you can't
you couldn't even explain to them how
low summit is
but the problem is but the problem is
where is the balance between
i mean if that kind of
thinking takes over of [ __ ] elitism
[ __ ] progression like yeah you know
and you don't need it that there's
plenty of countries where that takes up
like the other
way takes over and then you're in
present-day greece and that's not to
say anything negative about like greek
people
i'm just saying where they came from
just their system of government
and how and how they're handling it but
not them in particular
well yeah but know just how far
they've fallen from i mean there's so
many things we face
are everybody i mean it takes it took
them a while
yes yeah and and but
or even like mao mao mao preached like
no
nobody's above you you know you're
killing scientists
yeah that everyone's won yes which so
i'm where's the balance it's
i what what i think packer is
uh advocating is you can be elite
without being a [ __ ] snob
[Music]
i i honestly believe if i ever ran for
congress or something
which i never will but i would just
i would take like the suits i have i
would just go to men's warehouse i
wouldn't go to paul smith
do you know what i mean i would just go
to a place where like where can i get a
suit
that doesn't look cool at all
like let me just be sort of regular
instead of party or
superior in any way which i don't which
they don't want to do because
because then they they think they lose
the elites which is like
i'm gonna get the elites regardless let
me get people that aren't on my side
by nature but the problem is
you by the way you look and the way you
talk
and the way you hold yourself they
already know they can smell you
they already know like put on a
put on a pack a green bay packers shirt
and jeans
they still are gonna know that you're
kind of a snob
uh i think that i think a lot of it i
think more of it is appearance than
people would think
that's just personally what i think i
can't you would
like the fact that that larry the cable
guy had no sleeves on his shirt
helped honestly and like bill engvall
and and those guys don't dress
even sabbat the way sebastian dresses
he's starting to dress like a rich
person but like
slowly yeah no the tight thermals yeah
like he's he's the jackets are getting
like
into the thousand dollar range um
but like he still seems pretty pretty
regular like i think that's a big part
of it
or not a big part it's a bigger part of
it than
i think people would think again that's
just my own i didn't even know what
what made us talk about that i guess
well the funny thing is that i i don't
think you're wrong
but for example i was in an uber in
uh sebastian jacket
i was in an uber in new orleans
and this guy immediately went into
you know oh well you know it's just
it's basically the government's very
corrupt here and all this nonsense i
didn't want to talk about
and i had two choices was to either
school him
or shut the [ __ ] up and let him be wrong
and i'd let him be wrong for a while but
it was a long uber
and eventually he's like yeah well it's
basically we're basically turning into
el salvador i'm like that's
unequivoc that is absolutely not true
did you finally enter so
far from the corrupt i would i had to i
said
you have no idea the level of corruption
the level of corruption
in the world hasn't even graced our
shores
you have no idea well yeah that's what
we've talked about well
i'm like no no it doesn't i mean no
doubt no
we've talked about the fact that if you
don't hire your family in other
countries
you're that's more traitorous than
anything you do
up to the government like you have to
like you have to
you have to that would it would have
been i said it already i'll say it again
well but
whatever i'm the who when i'm nitpicking
um
but uh look if we're doing cues if we're
talking queues it would have been
that but uh but that's the yeah like
it's very corrupt we got a shot at it
though
always i think we're closer than we've
ever been right
so that's i think i think it would be
hard for
someone like you let's say you're on the
campaign trail you're
you got your men's warehouse suit i
think would be really hard for you to
hold your tongue
in the face of like just plain wrong
[ __ ]
did i i mean it's sort of like from the
from the
if i hear you correctly school and
arguing a way to argue with people no
negotiator guys
yeah it's like you know the negotiators
everybody lists every episode
um i see the numbers um the
but it's the it's the a thing i if i
ever
if the documentary stuff happens i think
i would do it like
i i i hear your point i'm not there yet
help me get there
you know that's good it's just a better
way so it's less yeah that's good
um it's less everyone walks away no one
feels
yeah yeah yeah anyhow
rest in power derek shelvin truly rest
take a load you're going on at the
administrative leave
12 by 12 feet administrative leave
um now bianca what do you make of this
miami collapse
the building
what do you think uh
well um i
one it's so sad but also
i don't know i you have you lived in a
lot of places with landlords i have
and i don't know
i'm not surprised a building collapsed
in america
yeah it's the people want to do as
little as they possibly can
landlords don't want to [ __ ] you've
lived in new york
right they're so notorious don't wanna
do work they don't wanna have to do
anything
so they don't want to upkeep they don't
want it no one takes pride in it
everyone thinks that everyone's trying
to [ __ ] them no all the time like
well these tenants are [ __ ] me and i
gotta go to court
and everyone's trying it's just
everyone's just [ __ ] elbowing
um right like i gave a guy in a
right before this i gave uh
the guy like a decent tip right and
you get into like why i wouldn't
like well because these this is my money
and i know that
it's like no i'm just [ __ ] selfish
it's not because like
he's these guys don't work that hard
believe me so
everyone just uses their own
self-interest to justify
their behavior and in this case you got
a little too self-interested there
landlord
and derek shovin's may
is preparing a is making a bed for you
because i'm guessing you're going to
some kind of jail
or i mean they've already almost proven
negligence just in the paper with like
the reports and the structural stuff and
all that stuff so like
um and uh there was a there was a
maintenance guy that took a
photo of all these structural issues
36 hours before collab i remember i
um now this isn't cool but i had an
indian landlord and one of my roommates
kept calling him slumdog
impression
[Music]
no don't dude
[ __ ] so racist
[Music]
i just tell myself that an indian guy
made that so
uh anyways so i
this guy this landlord bought it from
our old landlord
and when you buy a building the tenants
like right just like
this is what i this is this is how much
we pay around this you know the tenants
version of what's going on
so a few like weeks after you bought it
our pipes were terrible because it was
just an old-ass la house
and i was like hey um
sludge is backed up into this into the
tub
so what's up yeah the uh you know it
counts like three days it's called
sludgy tub go ahead
[Music]
you had sludgy top i got
guys i can't make it how come sludgy tub
no quit you know what bianca it's fine
honey take care of yourself
it's a tough time we had slubby touch
last week last
last week and it's hard sludgy tub
sludgy job sluggish valid valid reason
for being tardy so
uh so i had sludgy tub it took him three
days
i was like dude dejal gotta come over
here to joel
so he comes over and
he was like what's you didn't tell me
about this
like this all so he calls roto-rooter
rotary tells him it's going to be a 8
000 job and he yelled at us
saying we should have told him that the
plumbing was bad
in our like declaration letter i'm like
that's
so wrong i shouldn't have told you
anything i'm like did you have an
inspector come
so jaw leaves i don't hear from djall
for like five days and i was like dejal
you need to fix it i don't care how much
money it is
it's black sludge in our tub joe joe
and he all fixed the tub did y'all fix
the tub
go ahead i would constantly be saying
that
jawline is jowl on your way dude
go ahead
jajal responds with i will not do the
accent
if the uh building and the
accommodations
are not up to your standards feel free
to move
out uh oh i don't like that then i
called
then i i i karen i karen
i called the housing authority and they
called him and they said
all of your rent checks will be held
at the city until you fix it and what
would you know
huh this sounds like one of them things
is about to happen
just one of the mix-ups yeah
just what i we thought you said and
that's when i was like
dude la is very pro-renter
and something about will they'll pay
they'll pay the rent you won't get it
until you do your part
it motivates landlords i just don't get
it if i owned a building i would want it
to be
lovely i'd want to take care of the
people i i don't know i just
i i'm with you i i that's how i would
think of it too
and try to not make the maximum amount
of dollars i could make and
try to be a human being about it but
something happens
either it's the type of people that it
attracts
building ownership or something
like you get it's like one of those
things where
it just every time they just become
[ __ ]
chiselers it's a colin quinn term
um well they just become like she just
loses she's
such a great old-timey phrase um
they just get they just chisel people
for [ __ ] every
dime and you're like dude so you only
make
70 grand profit this year instead of 74.
but you have people that are happy to
live there and you're doing
you're being decent to a human being oh
hypothetical okay but this is the flip
side flip side is
i feel like there's an origin story in
every landlord
where they just got one really bad
tenant
yeah exactly no that's exactly right yes
where it's like
[ __ ] everyone yeah no you're absolutely
right
[ __ ] this and i don't know you just
gotta have to hope i mean the key is
maybe be that
you gotta to be that tenant if you
really wanna get ahead
you have to be the worst tenant ever for
every landlord and just help
tenants are you listening now's the time
guys we rise up and we don't pay
and we we repaint and we [ __ ] on the
our babe dogs [ __ ] on everything there's
ways to do it
it can be done um i'm the miami collapse
thing i will say they're in the
phase now where they say people are
missing
or unaccounted for and it's like they
can't say they're dead
but i mean maybe one person
i saw clip yesterday we're like we
expect miracles
don't sir do yourself a favor
i saw the miracle thing you know i was
like yeah oh god this set
that's so sad you're like why are you
doing this yourself
there's a like don't say that also
there's a bunch of structures in that
area that all have
similar issues yeah it's like that's
this building this time or it's this
section of the building this time
yeah a lot of those a lot of those some
of those florida condos feel like
they're made by
soviet union um where they're just
very likely like 60s
1960s design and
there's some l.a buildings like that
where it's just like very like
like where like yeah like where the
doors are on the outside and there's
just like a
walkway that's like a screened-in
walkway where there's no
interior oh it's just kind of like ah i
don't love it
uh uh when i first went to miami
i realized it's not as impressive
as you'd think architecturally
yeah it's not all bad boys
it's not all music videos in bed it's
not all dj khaled's house
or rick ross's house i thought it was
like sprawling and this
and they're all like kind of like
two-story apartment buildings
people are broke everywhere
like that's the thing it's like they're
[ __ ] broke there's bad neighborhoods
[ __ ] everywhere you were just in one
it's called mississippi
um anyhow what do you make what's
oh did you see the gay nfl guys
number one jersey number one selling
jersey right now
it's to uh haze people with kidding
um that's proof that
i was thinking about somebody
just how pandery it is to be like
pro
it's like being pro gay at this point is
just so like
it's so [ __ ] basic
that i'm happy that the jersey selling
and all that stuff but
some of it's like a bit of posturing on
the part of the people that buy it
although
we're in a gay guy's football jersey um
is a like it's sweet
um yeah but that's like
colin kaepernick everyone bought his to
like yeah people just do it
yeah but at least colin kaepernick was
like but we are in a game
mostly black people and some white
people i would say this is
i don't know i i don't think this is
mostly gay people
you know um
no i don't think so they're also we are
in a gay month
we're going to gabriel amount of
pandering yeah it's high it's at all
time high
and the amount of pandering is
everything is rainbow
yeah the funniest part is the the
corporations and the companies that
actively donate towards anti-gay like
most of them
i'm like yeah word yeah
yes word okay yeah they want everybody
i'm not surprised
they want the homophobes they want the
homosexuals they want the queer they
want the
they want all the the lg they want plus
they want minus
they want [ __ ] they want everybody i
want i literally was driving here
and i saw an atm and it had like rainbow
around it and i was like
y'all giving out gay money
like if just like the gay mu
what it what it's such an obvious it's
like
people who are
won't shut up about weed and it's like
dude it's legal
it's like we're pro gay why wouldn't you
would who
thought you were not pro-gay
um right it's just it's
it's some pandering uh i know you know a
football player is gonna tackle that guy
and in the huddle be like yo are you
still gay
just oh he's gonna get some the huddle
looks scary i don't like the huddle
i think that they're not gonna do i
think the other team will say [ __ ]
like i'm gonna knock the gay out of them
and all that [ __ ]
um by the time i'm done with them
at best he'll be bi i'ma [ __ ] him up so
bad
um so there was a there was a san
francisco player that
someone said you know because there's a
lot of gay people in san francisco and
he was like
there's no gay people in our team like
absolutely no one's gay on our team like
that yeah everybody
everyone's getting like what's the same
iranian president ahmadinejad
um i didn't know ahmadinejad played for
for san francisco
um yeah but they really were like
yeah they think also it's again this is
one of those things where
one of these [ __ ] has to be
dope somebody like the leading run
if they're leading a runner the leading
running back
was gay that [ __ ] would be delightful
because it's one of those things where
it's one of those things it's
it's like at the end of his career like
if barry sanders a guy retired like
toward the top or evan smith or one of
those guys like
by the way gay
you just rooted for for a homo for the
last 15 years
um do you think that'd be fine or would
people be like
no yeah they'd be fine with it they'd be
like i didn't know we was all that
um but really because i know people who
ripped their wheaties box with uh
bruce jenner on it well he went too far
with him
no i don't
um no yeah i hear you i but i don't
think it'll get to that i feel like
people
you don't think there's going to be do
you think people are going to support at
this point or do you think people
yeah that's not if you can't
even like in the like the holdouts
like you know i still think
that there's uh there's a it just gets
better every year
and seems to get easier every year which
is cool like it's cool to see that
it's probably a bit like what
inner marriage was where it was like
harry belfonte kissed a one couldn't
kiss a woman
and then and then the loving first state
of virginia
happened like it's every five years it's
just like these milestones that
that will probably be hit just like
so but again if you're if you're
out there and you want to be
if you want to really help gay people be
dope
at football and then sneak attack them
surprise [ __ ]
that's that's how we get them um
and then uh what's the avenue some rent
thing
we're moving on will oh he literally is
just
he'll put it in he would
he just um he's gonna pay
every single californians background
from last april
100 of it i knew i shouldn't have bought
that stupid thing
everyone now is i'm [ __ ]
everyone's people are complaining
people are complaining like damn it well
i paid my rent
and it's like okay are you gonna get
reimbursed some people did it
like is it gonna aren't are the people
that no no
that paid gonna get reimbursed no what
well why wouldn't
it's like the it's like the uh the covet
lottery thing like we were entering into
the lottery
even though you could afford to pay your
rent so you paid
yeah there was a memorandum you didn't
have to well
you know i don't follow all the memos i
mean that was your bed a deer
you you you been on the wrong horse well
i better get on the wrong course
you shouldn't have paid your age i
[ __ ] up again
thank you um
hold on i'm just adjusting the light um
[Music]
and are you did you pay your rent
yeah i mean i have like hoa dudes
do you have to pick your aj yeah i'm
sure i did
yeah um did you pay yours
somebody did yeah i paid
i paid my [ __ ] i wasn't holding out i
mean there was a point where
like my account was like you are
technically eligible for
a ppp loan and then he was like ah this
is not gonna look good
no like don't do it no it may come down
to
if they ever if anyone ever audits this
it's gonna just look goofy
it's not going to look good will you
just move yeah you move the blue just
turn it yeah
um yeah it's going to look it's not
going to look good so i didn't do it
no it's not going to look good um but i
just think it's funny
now i'm like how are you going to recall
a guy that opened up your state
and that would be all right i mean it's
they're going to
technically go through with it but he's
going to win 70 percent
i would i will vote for it it's like
you know what i mean like that's one of
those things like you [ __ ] you're
making it sound like
i don't normally you're gonna get up and
go
like if it's a separate i haven't no
recall policy where are you
where were you during grade davis yeah
exactly like what happened there
um yeah i haven't historically the one
recall i lived through i'm old enough to
have voted during the last recall hi i'm
neil brennan
i'm wearing a flubby suit uh guys i'm
i'm not there yet
um uh
good good for him good for him with the
rent
um it's like i know it's cool it's yeah
it's like people are worried about all
these corporations moving out of
california meanwhile
california has never been flush with
buying it's like
apple ain't moving and they
pay state taxes i believe
um the nccaa we're moving on well we're
moving on we'll
we're moving on and i'm not [ __ ]
around thank you
um ncaa
ruled yesterday that that they um
their slaves can't i mean their athletes
can um
profit from their likeness which is
excellent and i wonder
how much i wonder how many of them will
be able to get endorsements
and will they will women watch a thing
on it
so i watched a thing on it one they only
they only
said they can make money because the
supreme court it's coming
so they just yeah no it wasn't like they
did this by their own
[ __ ] volition they were like you know
it's funny
you know we were thinking about this and
you know what this just
sort of you know gets us moving and
keeps us on us and it's like no you're
still the most corrupt organization on
earth
and these people are slaves um
they're slaves they're weight they're
slaves so
100 slaves so here's the cool thing one
of course like
men's sports especially basketball and
football
they're gonna be fine um but the women's
i read a thing that i watched i i did
both how like because of a lot of the
women in their field garner a lot of
social media followings
yeah they'll be able to maybe it won't
be a popular it's not as popular as
other things but
in their field they're extremely popular
so they can now get endorsements third
party endorsements
through anything and it's like they
literally the women will be just as fine
now they can do
things like um hold like coaching
seminars
and do like just make just hustle
literally
they could all hustle because now
they're gonna be like
great at what they do i would like yeah
it's i don't i
for for college athletes there's
obviously like the football and
basketball dudes
who will be stars and there's usually
like
right and they'll be stupid it'll be the
one guy
per team basically in the town
like in indiana at university of indiana
the best basketball player
will get a [ __ ] local pizza deal
you know what i mean like or local car
dealership or local
whatever local uh aluminum siding or
like whatever just like
small [ __ ] a couple of them will be
national like the heisman winner will
those guys will be able to but but i'm
more interested
in the women like that where they can
they don't have to make just like give
them two grand a month or something
just give them a thing that will help
them live and not
not be slaves and not be
uh totally beholden to these weird
[ __ ] byzantine ass rules
weird yeah like
just weird and also most of these people
this
is their uh peak of their
you know athletic career is in college
most of them aren't going on to play
professionally
sometimes there's not a there's not a
like huge viewership
so especially for women the women that
are
uh fans of that sport
they they get to just like have a more
focused demographic that
they can get money off of which i'm like
like there's people in cheer
that are famous yeah i don't know them
you don't know them no
we don't give a [ __ ] but maybe the other
people in cheers like oh she can go help
practices hey
blah blah blah whatever yeah hustle
yep do a basketball camp get a little
bit of money
yeah don't be a slave why not you don't
got a slave like that
um yo what if they had what if they had
scholarships for
what if they had comedy scholarships go
ahead
would i would i go to school i'm just
thinking is there
the only reason i got into nyu is
because my essay was funny and my movie
was funny
i didn't [ __ ] my dude i got that 10
70 on my sats like
a bad score oh my god neil
like six out of 1600 10
70. but i made a funny short just wrote
his
yeah i made a funny short and they were
like yeah this guy's funny
and i i always think like were they
right to let me in or wrong
i mean look around but i dropped out
do you know what i mean like i'm not
saying obviously i work right
but you know what i mean like was it
good for nyu
obviously it was good for the world it's
not a
i mean look it's not about that it's
about the fact that they saw they
actually
oddly enough despite your trash
s.a.t score and like like 100 in my
class
like not impressive at all out of 300
right not good
they still saw something that was that
was good even if it didn't work there
it's like
was rock being on snl good for snl like
i don't know
did he do that good i'm not sure but he
i didn't want to say that but
nah
[Music]
right right yeah no like lauren it's
still like one of those things where
it's a good call by lauren
and it's like maybe this format also
when you go to snl it's like
this is really it's a different yes it's
like theatrical
yeah it's a different thing it's the
actual it's like
when you like i watch a show called top
chef
and when they do a reunion they're like
you literally gotta think i take
two months to think of a recipe and i
gotta think of a recipe
in like 15 minutes like i don't work
like so
just i feel like people have their
different processes but
i think chris rock show is streaming on
hbo by the way
chris rock show now no it's everywhere
now yeah go watch it
watch uh watch the allen iverson one
that's a very good
i don't know if that's that one's good
that one's good um there's a bunch of
the and there's
the you know what to go with the arsenio
one because they did a really
puffy was the musical guest literally
that was his name back then
and they did a great [ __ ] skit they
did a great sketch
um but uh yeah so let the
let them wait i kind of want to see your
short dude where's your shoulder oh i
don't know can we see your shoulders uh
uh no it's just like neil this is your
legacy
oh my god i don't believe in legacy
you'll see it's in the new show don't
care i know i know
don't care i don't care i don't care um
does anybody see this story um
anybody see this right um
what do you got anybody see this story
i have a bunch go well we did gay of nfl
today
so bad a gay uh
hilarious this guy won the lottery and
just
to accept his winnings in a screaming
incredibly smart family wouldn't
recognize incredibly smart
i thought of you i was like neil would
endorse the [ __ ] out of this
it's a great move it's just good um
and it's so funny because everyone's
very official and
that's so funny it'd also be funny if it
turned out to be david arquette
um i didn't i never did was he behind
this green mask i don't even remember is
it jamie kennedy
is that who it is yeah yeah it was um or
no it was one of no no no it was
it was david or the blonde
oh yeah it was uh matt lillard matthew
lillard
right yeah he was like a very 90s yeah
yeah
90s 2000s face yep um i read this
a long article on um
it's not nobody i don't think anybody
else would find it interesting but it's
about just lotteries so this guy did
all these studies on lotteries and there
are some states
where you they have to publish your name
mm-hmm
by law yeah and then there's some states
where you can be completely anonymous
[Music]
different states yeah states i believe
it's
i'm a big state's rights guy so i'm for
this
oh and then yeah he said
be so you guys don't have to read it he
said oh
never ever take the annuity
always take the lump sum who the guy in
the article
the study that yeah that guy that wrote
the whole thing and he he
he like surveyed all these people in
their lives before and after and which
one to do
because they give you options oh that's
never take the annuity
yeah because you because he said that
yeah when you go
yeah why do you say why but why do you
say because you get to invest
yourself because when you break it down
even though you get more of the money
the buying power of it is so
little and you end up everybody ended up
getting life circumstances where they
needed more of their money and then they
had to do those weird things the reverse
mortgage
kind of cellular and nudity yeah that
kind of silly
i have a cash settlement and you need
you know that commercial
yeah you know what's funny there was uh
this will be mine do you see this story
there was a guy come on on hbo real
sports
a show that i watch a doc watch show um
where there is a guy and this is the
thing i've always thought about doing
there's a guy who will go you know minor
league baseball players
live like five or six to a room i mean
sometimes
obviously it's not that bad but they
make like three what do you mean a room
or like a hotel
no like uh like they live they make like
380
a week sometimes like being a minor
league baseball player at certain levels
is as bad a job as you can possibly have
right
it's like very time fulfilling no money
right
um so these guys are you know top ramen
[ __ ] like just living off scratch like
he'd say he
caught it he found a guy dumpster diving
like they're
they're very very cool they're like if
not at the poverty line they're just
above it
so this guy who was a former baseball
player does a thing now
where he invests in baseball players
based on their stats and
oh right but he'll give them uh
a 300 000
no questions asked but he gets 10 of
their lifetime earnings
and it's one of those things where i'm
like and they were like oh there's
there's
a devil yes and no like
if if um
[Music]
here's what i'll say the the big
complaint was from this guy
scott boris who's a like the one of the
biggest baseball
agents ever and did like a rod steal
he's done a ton of big people
and scott boris most of those agents get
four percent
right so this guy is getting
10 but at least he [ __ ] did something
for them
scott boris didn't do [ __ ] he negotiated
the best possible deal he could
after they put themselves after their
stats got so good
after they put in they could literally
go to arbitration court
and and uh get a better salary so i was
like
i'm sort of on the guy's side and i
always used to a joke of like i wish i
could do that in comedy
she's like you're gonna make it you need
some money oh
um and you know what's funny though yeah
now that i think about
what you're saying the amount of times
where i'm like
that guy you this is something special
and then fast forward not everyone lives
in la
they come from other places and then
they get
they start drinking they start partying
yeah well that's the other thing i would
have lost a lot of money yeah yes
there are people i mean they're really i
don't know if they do much lifestyle
[ __ ] one guy complained and said like
he needed his family needed money in
dominican republic so
um so like he
they needed money and um
right but i'm kind of like yeah i'm not
mad at anybody
and one of the now the sort of irony is
one of the guys
is that guy tatis that i did the
gatorade commercial with
right and it's like i benefited i
benefited from that guy giving him a
loan
in a weird way and they don't get any by
the way they don't get any of your
endorsement money
so it's just if you make a dime from
major league baseball
they get 10 of it for as long as you
make i it was
it was very interesting and i thought it
was like
what's it called like what is that
system called like is it uh
i don't know what they call the the i
can't remember that oh it's just a guy
uh yeah no he's got a bunch of employees
and but he's just a guy who
uh lives in it looked like he lived in
philly but or florida
um but he played for the phillies and
just like i don't remember his name but
he looks like a real the guy looks like
a douchebag
um the guy who does it you just go oh
that guy yeah that guy looks like a
douchebag
so let's just show me images the dugout
push in let me show bianca that guy
sitting in the dugout
yeah you know just like douchey looking
yeah um just like douchey yeah but
[ __ ] it like good system
i mean it's true though like the amount
of the people that come from latin
america
that are like 300 000 is
fine and in a way it's an investment
that you can
you can keep playing i mean he says it's
like they can get good nutrition and
they can do stuff
that's trueish but
but it's definitely helpful it just is
helpful
like whatever if you want to yeah one
guy he's getting 15 percent of some so
whatever so they can negotiate
a little bit but they're in their entire
straits but they used to do it a lot
with
uh boxers like um
requiem for a heavyweight this old movie
it's like like i need you to take a fall
it's that [ __ ]
um oh yeah like muhammad ali
i think had investors in them like a lot
of george foreman
like that type of guy um like
rich i think i think mike tyson had in
had guys who
sort of funded him for a cut of it
that's some chisely shoes it's some
chiseler yeah it's a chisel it's a
chisel it's for sure for chiselers
chiselers for [ __ ] for chiselers i meant
to say for chisels
for scissors for shiz shizzles chiselers
no no no neil
is a wigger black man here
go ahead we're moving on okay all right
let's move on
um okay so
i got an oculus
[Music]
something an oculus quest too
[Music]
no this is a wonderful purchase
no no and i bought it because of my
vision issues i take vision class
in the um in the oculus
one of the classes it's pretty dumb i'll
demonstrate it i need my
well i guess i don't need my hands but
basically i'm wearing the oculus
and because my left and right eyes are
not
in in sync
um i pick an eye every time do i tell
you that
i'm basically always picking an eye when
i'm looking at someone i'm just
my brain has picked an eye for me to
look at them with
and the other eye is just off see so i'm
training myself i think that's normal uh
well i don't think it is and so what
i've had to do is
when i'm looking through both eyes i'm
seeing double
i'm basically training myself to see
double all the time
uh which is pretty crazy like when
you're say
driving um but
so i'm seeing double right now i'm
literally seeing two screens
two uh cameras um and
what so is there a reason to see double
what happens is i'm gonna see
double for a while and then finally my
brain will be like [ __ ] it let's unify
it
and bring them together so within the
oculus this
most people i would say this is not what
the oculus is for
um there's a game where it where
where i i am i'm basically a hoop
i'm basically a basketball uh backboard
that's my pov and with one eye
i see the rim and then in the other eye
i see the balls coming at me
so i have to like move my head
[Music]
to catch the balls and it's really
dumb and rudimentary there's another one
this one's actually very hard where i'm
where i'm speaking of mississippi i'm
picking fruit
[Music]
so i'm with my left hand and right hand
it is
3d and it's like you have to pick two
red peppers
and then there's two trees and i'm like
looking around
trying to see with both eyes because
obviously in one eye is the leaves the
other eye
is the peppers and the oranges i'll tell
you what's hard is that
is the uh so is the uh the
the dick what's the dick emoji the
eggplant the eggplants are so hard to
find
eggplant i guess maybe because i'm so
straight and i love women
so much i'm so heterosexual i can't even
see them
uh but it that's very fun also because
this
is
watching move into yeah it'll absolutely
it makes me it's better like i'm seeing
more double i have to like force myself
to see double um
and i've just been watching netflix on
it and you can bring netflix and youtube
like movie theater innocuous it's
[ __ ]
unbelievable the youtube
uh i was espn's on there
uh so i watched basketball in there like
like [ __ ]
super like would have to be a like 110
inch screen anywhere else uh that's very
exciting
i i can't i'm just imagining you
with your like those things that help
you
walk with your posture and your i've got
a lot of things that i'm doing at all
times bianca
never s never stu i'm like uh what's the
the gnaws never stop never settle what's
your
white wrap it's for bacardi who's that
for
that's i'm the book i'm about to pop off
a bacardi
never settle neil brennan
pick one eye at a time the reference is
too old no it's
it's active it's an active nas this is
an active noz voiceover we have an
active nod voiceover
uh attention all units uh we have an
active nod voiceover
um so i
recommend the oculus high across there's
a ping-pong game
that is so fun but you can't believe how
fun it is
you can't this is just a regular oculus
game you can play against
other people their avatar shows up your
avatar shows up
the funniest thing of course was
uh i did it and uh i went online
and i linked up with a 12 year old
boy i don't know where he was but he
immediately called me the n-word
immediately oh yeah the funniest
we used to do i wanted to do a sketch on
chapel show called clan rally
or uh chat room um
immediately call me the n-word which is
[ __ ] great that's why
when people are mad that like hunter
biden
like white children across
this country n bombs
for all time they've been doing it it's
nothing new
for all time they've been doing it
they've been doing this for for since
since the 1600s um what
what am i not supposed to say okay i'm
going to say that that's
that's the teenagers that's the 12 year
old's creed
um they have a creed
[Music]
for god sakes bianca there's a creed um
there's a new netflix series called
pop did you watch it
it's good it's just about pop music
songwriting it's eight
parts um and they're
i didn't watch the country one but the
there's one with t-pain in it that's
pretty great
like you will love tv that's the one
yeah where he got hurt
hurt his feelings um you know what's
crazy
t-pain is like 36.
is that old or young
he just looks like he's in his 40s yeah
yeah he's mostly way older than that a
gamer it also seems like
his sound was 70 years ago
um but but even the story of how he came
to that sound
he was in a he was in like a rap group
where they
uh he sang the hooks and then
then they i guess they broke up or
something and he was like i need
i can't just be a singer like that's not
going to be good enough
she's from tallahassee right by the way
he did a lord remix that's
one of the blackest songs i've ever
heard um he did a
remix of royals that look it up
so great um anyhow
but and he was like i'm gonna be a
singer i need to figure out
uh a way to make myself better
and he'd heard it wasn't even cher's
song
it was a song it was from a compilation
so he
said he just looked for plug-ins
production plug-ins
from anyone who would talk to him for
years he was looking for a way to
get his voice like that and then he
finally found
the plugin i was like okay now i can
release an album
um and uh
and i the song it's like singer who raps
or something or
rapper turned singer is the name of the
album and
and then kanye which i didn't realize
kanye
basically everyone hated autotune and
then connie did it on that and 808 in
heartbreaks
the whole the whole album and he told
d-paint ahead of time like this is gonna
this shit's gonna work
um because he's kanye so that was pretty
don't
people generally dislike that album
uh no i don't think they do i think
that's probably people's
i think that's a better album than
people think that's my experience with
it was like
he was the first i think he paved the
way for like
you know frank ocean in them
um by making an album that was just sort
of like
not that musical
like more abstract i don't know yeah um
and that was good there was one called
cheating death there are two parts
that were about mediums psychic mediums
which of course i am
believe in now so that was great for me
oh yeah and
um and then there's an amy tan
documentary the writer amy tan
asian guys i love amy asian gal
very good documentary joy look very good
documentary
i love amy very good highly recommend
okay interesting woman
and like very
you know representation before
representation [ __ ] came out like 28
years ago
and like uh cool and a cool woman with a
cool life
so that's my doc watches now
you you were in the south a lot of times
i flew [ __ ]
i flew across the country
[Music]
[ __ ] i flew i [ __ ] i i take the amtrak
yeah you were on the train
they don't got wi-fi on the train they
got landline they had someone chase you
with a landline
um well there's some audio videos right
[Music]
he didn't even respond to you
[Music]
you've got mail hello neil and pinky
rst l e a question for the amazing
binkerton
how did you become multilingual and hey
why did you always love language
learning and
it just come easy to you also i used to
be
conversant not fluent in german a long
time ago
spent a summer in cologne and would love
to get it back
and i wondered if you had any tips for
what apps you like or methods that you
use now
to learn a language if you have any
other tips for someone who wants to
learn
thanks so much this guy i just got to
say right now this guy's using
this is a guy who's trying to make small
talk he might also have said like
hey miss which way is the park
he don't care about none of this [ __ ]
look it up ding dong
i have a question bianca is bilingualism
natural do you miss
miss where you headed oh
he did have fake he did have a fake bird
sound in the background
you know what's funny he used the birds
from the beginning of loving you by
minnie riperton
um if you play well if you can drop that
in
just to be um that is uh of course maya
rudolph's
and it's the same birds
um it really is anyhow i don't think
yeah answer it quickly because i don't
want to dignify that oh it's not a it's
not no
he's matt neil's mad you've guys using
[ __ ]
my entertainment outlet to to mack on
chicks
google yeah google it basically
i come from two both my friends speak
different languages
i think i'm there's predisposition there
i've always loved language loving i've
always been good at languages and i've
picked up german like in one year
i live and then when i was in germany
i learned russian in german i learned
like i'm just
weird i can i like learning languages in
different languages
because it solidifies i'm kind of
learning them both at the same time so
for me when i try to read and write
cyrillic and like think and
like speak russian it's easier for me to
think in german
so i think i'm just a weirdo um i know
almost
everything in like a lot of language
a lot of languages i don't like any of
the [ __ ] apps i think they're
[ __ ] rosetta stone
do what's the duolingo no
people like that i don't like because
it's just because it's just memory
but you're not for someone who who did
who like excelled at german before i got
to germany
that [ __ ] all that shit's out the window
when you get there you're like
[ __ ] i'm on it's like no you just it's
like learning you're not gonna
it's like bad learning lines so i would
say
especially now during the pandemic you
can hire really cheap tutors
that just like virtual tutors and just
talk with someone once a week
that's it i also like traditional so i
like classes i like to know
i is blank and you are blank i like
rules
so i know what i'm doing um but i
i don't like the apps i think the apps
are a waste of money just pay
a real person to talk to you okay okay
well what else we got
i hope that guy's uh come on will go
ahead
wait what go ahead what did you say i
hope that guy that guy feels uh
now that's the thing where the guy
walked away was like i didn't want to go
to no
park give a [ __ ] about lingo i was
hoping he was like she answered it
sparked some [ __ ] i was hoping she'd go
yeah i like them birds [ __ ]
where are you
at i'm coming to where the birds are
those birds
ear out the window looking for birds
[ __ ] out of here bird ass [ __ ]
go ahead birdman banks
firstly i would like to point out that
neil unraveled his entire argument
about kevin at the end of the episode
last week
you said in comedy if it's over 70
it's all and comedians talk and
superlatives
this argument gives cover to kevin as
lest i checked that's what he is
i would also add when he says ever one
can assume he's limiting that to
his own lifespan not all of human
history
anyways i do have a more serious
question that i've been mulling over
um and i think you and binks are the
perfect cross-section
to answer although maybe a uk black
adjacent
would be suit most suitable
for context a white female
who grew up in the inner city of detroit
on the east side
you know got called shannene my kids on
the block got labeled the whitest little
black girl
got my cookout punch card suffice it to
say i have
a mostly accurate detection of racism in
media
and you know people talking
even when it's the underhanded or
microaggression kind
my husband by contrast is a londoner and
i moved to the uk to be with him
so the question i put to you is how do i
not
browbeat my new husband or others i meet
here
without with pointing it out all the
time
am i just a loud american
by pointing it out i don't always want
to have
long drawn out debate over whether
something is or isn't
racist or about race
i often open it up by saying something
rather casual but
even that i found can trigger a sigh
or a not everything has to be about race
sort of response i understand i probably
don't have as much chill
as i should about a lot of things being
a
loud american in their world
this is the one that i thought if i have
the energy isn't it my duty to kind of
never chill
so how do i turn it off or should i
what's your guidance spirit padre and
madre
help an admission system
will will you follow that up with a long
ass letter as well
[Music]
yeah and that's what i think and cut it
down
[Music]
great and and hopefully you'll edit the
letter down just
jesus christ jesus lady do they have
different
does is time different in england
no one i don't care is she white
yeah is she white this lady oh
she's white so she's taking she's she's
you oh lady
cut it give it a rest you're
so is her husband white
yeah yeah she's just a white lady who
had a different experience and then in
england she's realizing like damn y'all
are you no you shouldn't say that you
shouldn't say that should i keep
policing people should i let them be
what do i do as a white woman that knows
better
well this kind of is tied to the kevin
argument
uh by the way kevin wasn't being a
comedian when he was saying that
and there are times where the 70 or more
in order to get a la that's about
getting a laugh and something being true
anyhow i like how guys called a hit on
you
leave voice memos to hit on you and to
argue with me
now um they get the show um
i like isn't aren't you kind of like
nauseated by this no not i mean she
sounds like a nice lady but just like
ugh
i'm sure british people are like what
well also like i don't know i have a lot
of international friends and
there's times where i i don't go around
scolding people but i do say like
i i don't really say that like
like there was a british person that's
ghetto
that's gay that's get i was like
i you know we're we don't really say
ghetto anymore
right but that's is she here is she in
america
no no she's in london but where where
are we where was she saying where was
the woman that you corrected
stationed where was she oh [ __ ] she was
stationed here yeah it's like don't
be going to other people's countries and
then bringing american
social values it's like that's just not
or
it's or is it the whitest thing you can
do which is
colonialize she's england in england
which is colonializing she's
colonialized wokeness
yes she's colonialized she's franchising
wokeness
in a place where they don't even have
the numbers aren't the same the history
is not the same
i'm sure no one cares what you think in
what they do in america like also coming
from a white
woman from america yeah i mean might be
a little more impactful i just think it
it will set her up to be uh
dislike not having a good time disliked
and
scoldy but at the same time
silence is violence so right well of
course
except except that it's not um
no what does she do if like some shit's
just like not cool what would you do
let a not cool if it's there and if it's
their cult
i don't understand their culture enough
to say
what you should and shouldn't say or
their history
even if it was pretty racist and you
didn't need to know their culture enough
to understand it was
probably something [ __ ] look if an
american woman
met jimmy carr at the pub or the
the tea house i don't know what where
they drink too he doesn't go
uh he must go to i'm sure he goes to a
club some kind of club some kind of
private pub
he probably has pub in his house for all
i know um and she was
telling him about what's appropriate and
inappropriate based on american values
it's like get the [ __ ] out of here
how about this yeah get the [ __ ] out of
here
um so that's what i'm doing i have a
friend that's i have a
lovely british friend and i'm always
calling british people chavs because i
think it's hilarious it's a very
hilarious concept
it's just basically white trashy it's
just
a term for white trashy um you know
those british people in
uh snatch that like you would not [ __ ]
with working class but they
also have like yeah or well no
jabs are different they they're a little
um tacky
they're like but they'll knock your
[ __ ] head off girl guy
you're not messing with these people
okay i always think it's hilarious i'm
like you're a jab you're a jab
chat and then my friend was like they
were they were jogging outfits
everywhere those people
yeah they were track suits yeah and then
my friend said
explain to me that chav's not cool
because i watched a channel four
documentary on chats i was like cool i
like these people
uh right but you're again you're playing
a different game
which is if in a if someone in england
tells you chap's not cool
fine no that's my no that's my point is
that
that like he said you know what chav
stands for
council housing which is projects
council housing
and violent so that's what you're kind
of
that's where the origins come from and
that's when i'm like
oh thank you yeah i don't know i
still think this but right a lady
walking around
is can it everybody can count it i look
i'm against she
opened she tried to she tried to fool
the old
she opened aggressive toward me
and i know i'm like i'm still agreeing
with you
yeah she's got a cannon like who gives a
[ __ ]
um it's like yo hello you know what it
is oh go ahead go
go no go go go go oh i was gonna say
it's
uh didn't we agree that adele when she
dressed
for the caribbean day it was
it was their jurisdiction it was a
jurisdiction and it was a red card at
best
yeah you remember it was a misdemeanor
there was a misdemeanor
i used their term their football
yeah um but imagine saying
walking up to adele at that parade and
telling her it was wrong
as an american woman like [ __ ]
um anyhow hello all
i'm writing this in my phone so please
excuse formatting and typos
feel free to edit so it sounds better on
the air i'm not sure how to make this
funny or cute but i'm just going to
explain best i can't been married for
eight years and we have two kids
our marriage is basically fine which is
about as good as a marriage can be
basically fine my husband is always like
skinny dipping
etc i started to notice that when we
were dating
that's the funny one he was skinny that
when camping etc or nighttime swimming
fine all as things progressed i noticed
he was googling lots of nudist stuff
he brought me to a few clothing optional
beaches
fine not entirely my thing but i'm like
cool at night he always takes his
clothes off and walks around and almost
100 of the time sleeps nude
i'm not offended or anything but i'd be
lying if i said something about
uh it isn't a turn on um
something about it isn't a turn on
constantly seeing him nude is just eh
he's hot too by the way but there's no
sensuality to it it's all there
uh he did run he did a run yesterday and
later told me it was a nude run
he was he wasn't honest ahead of time
which kind of pissed me off
i like how women are mad that
again they're finding ways to get mad
about like you lied to me about the new
jogging okay no i'm not worried about
that body
yeah but where was it it's not like it
was that [ __ ]
the grades at the high school track uh
i'm not worried about him cheating and
quite frankly
a lot of clothing optional cultures
about freedom he's also a black dude
who is reclaiming his body or some crap
he has this innate need to do it i'm
i'm just not into it so it's not every
anniversary
or time alone he wants us to do nude
stuff he also
doesn't like going to the comedy cellar
which i do
and he holds that over me as a woman i
would say
i have less of a need to do this but i'm
also realizing it's not going anywhere
this dude is deaf going to want to
retire in some nudist colony somewhere
anyway what neil beliel and what's
binky belinky uh signed a
textile in brooklyn uh
this is he's holding nudity like well if
you don't let me be new then i won't go
to the comedy seller
um that's very funny um
and it seems harmless
there actually is a chris rock sketch
about this
um but about a guy who black dude is
naked all the time
um who like is he comes on to complain
about not being able to catch cabs and
then they cut them and he's naked
um i
i guess i would say just be careful well
i get here's a question
[Music]
that i would ask the white the white
people
what's more frightening a naked black
guy jogging
or a a black guy
jogging with a hoodie
[Music]
also if you're wearing sneakers is that
naked
i have a lot of questions um do you have
a do you have an opinion
about what's more danger what's more
terrifying to whites
no i don't know i'm never happy to see a
naked a naked man
ever yeah you don't like making this
[ __ ] everything though
no you got mad at her and i think you're
just still
mad at the last lady but you know
he should tell her when he's gonna go
outside naked i don't think that
i didn't think he was black i didn't
know he was black
the fact that he's black naked black
jogging
is scarier to white people than naked
white jogging oh naked white doggy you
go
oh he's in a club oh he must have
forgotten his shirt and pants or he's
quirky
whereas where uh a black guy naked
running and go oh he's uh
he's he's kanye he's uh out of his mind
he's lost his mind
yeah you wouldn't want if you if you
think of a girlfriend you loved
go there neil imagine if she just like
walked in your house every day just like
butt ass naked but it was already
outside like at air juan and stuff like
you wouldn't like that again
he didn't she said he didn't say it was
heroin he went naked jogging
it wasn't at night i just think it's a
that's dangerous and you got
kids so well
i think i think you gotta i think you
gotta be careful with the naked jogging
but otherwise what happens
she should just ask him how naked how
how
into this are you it seems like she
keeps going like yeah he's into this but
she never addresses it directly yeah
like she needs to address it directly
like is this your thing
is this it and what if it's what if he's
like
it is and it's not her thing divorce
just because of nakedness
no i don't no i think it's like okay
but now she's right in that she's
worried about they're gonna have to
retire to a nudist colony
you know which wouldn't which again
that's it feels like most
feels like either half of nudist
colonies are
retirement communities or half of
retirement communities are also in the
news community
there does they do seem to go hand in
hand i guess maybe because you got what
else do you have to lose other
i mean gravity's already pulling
everything down
out of place i
uh uh when i lived in san diego there
was a
there's a nudist beach called block
speech and
oddly enough and uh
when it was cold like not
warm at all it would be freezing people
would have
a winter jacket a shirt
shoes socks no pants
dick it so then you i just i
that there's a category of porn like
that which is like
cf it's male
nudity clothed female or something or
male
naked male 1 yeah
it's a whole thing where guys wearing
like woody and the women he's naked and
the women are like
having a wine and cheese party and
they're like come on out
and they kind of mock them and they're
jerking them off
by the way i'm not going to say if you i
meant to say this in the oculus segment
bianca if you've ever wondered what it's
like to be a guy during sex
get an oculus and go on the vr porn
sites it's a true pov
it's crazy
it's is it better uh
well it's better in certain respects the
you want ready for the part that's not
better
when you're finishing you have to like
tear your mask off and
because you can't see so yeah it adds a
layer
of terror to
to the ending because you literally
cannot see
yeah that's right thank you we have a
song for every minute
there's a song for that um right
so that's pretty great so they gotta be
careful and we gotta wrap this up
because i gotta go to i gotta go to
dinner
okay i don't have to we don't have to
take this [ __ ]
listen sorry for the lateness but
we'll get we'll get it this is our first
one we'll get a groove you guys
i love you guys all right it ended this
is a sudden ending
but it's now life it's like this is like
an oculus this is like an oculus
ejection
oculus oculus ejaculation
any oculus thank you very much ma'am
um you get it all right we'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Music]
you tell um
[Music]